happy vlogmas day two and this is a day
two gift that is very close to my heart
because these are iJustine signature
cables that I partner with Condor blue
on we have a bunch of USBC cables we've
also got lightning cables which I
thought that this year the iPhone wasn't
going to be lightning and I thought we
wouldn't need these well we do we've
also got this incredible little bag this
was exactly what I wanted a little
travel pouch to be so I'm so excited
they executed on it perfectly and it's
so beautiful these are also all
available for purchase so even if you
don't win them you can still purchase
them and I could not be more excited
about these because the pink is it's
like the perfect color pink so hyped so
to enter don't forget just go to
ijustine.com blogmas for all of the
details